damit jeder seine zeit heute hat bleiben
wir direkt bei der bh es gibt ja noch
ein anderes thema was deutschland bewegt
außerhalb der datenerhebung das ist die
impfpflicht das ist die impfpflicht und
ja ich habe mich aufgeregt in dem
zusammenhang über christian drosten auch
das tut man nicht in deutschland bei
christian drosten ist hier sozusagen ein
säulenheiliger und jeder der in
kritisiert ist auch wissen zumindest in
einer anderen community ich mache es
trotzdem denn christian drosten hast
jetzt einblick gegeben wie er sich den
besten schutz vor corona vorstellt
wahrscheinlich hat er lange geforscht um
das herauszufinden aber er hat gesagt
und ich zitiere hier die ideale
immunisierung ist dass man eine
vollständige immunisierung hat also drei
dosen gerümpft geimpft und gepostet und
sich dann zieht weiter erstmalig und
auch zweit malik und tritt malik mit dem
virus infiziert also übersetzt heißt das
einmal zweimal dreimal impfen danach
einmal zweimal dreimal infizieren dann
bin ich bestmöglich geschützt wer das
durchgemacht hat so professor thorsten
weiter seien wahrscheinlich über jahre
immun und werde sich dann nicht mehr
infizieren dabei die stimme die
intensität der infektion mit wie
anhaltende impfschutz sein kann
die biologin sandra zeck die wir gerade
gesehen haben hat in ihrem podcast
gesagt man soll die folgen von long
goodbye unicom nicht unterschätzen also
im grunde das gegenteil gesagt als er
ich finde christian drosten hat mit
seinen äußerungen impft bewegungen tort
angetan denn es geht ja um millionen
menschen die bisher noch nicht geimpft
sind die wir überzeugen wollen oder
dahin bringen wollen mit der impfpflicht
sich impfen zu lassen damit wir alle
hier rauskommen aus dieser zweig plus
oder zweig regelungen aus dem mini
lockdown oder motto a night in der
gerade abend aber wie will ich den
menschen und das muss ich ja tun
nahebringen dass eine impfung für sie
richtig ist dass die impfpflicht richtig
ist wenn mit der oberste virologe sagt
also im grunde um euch richtig zu
schützen müsst ihr euch drei mal impfen
dreimal infizieren und dann wird die
impfung auf dauer deswegen muss ich
sagen aus dieser geschichte bin ich
jetzt raus eine impfpflicht und den sinn
dafür kann ich nach diesen äußerungen
das muss ich leider unterstützen weil
herr thorsten jemand ist er schon sehr
früh zu sehen gewesen ist er hat damals
am 29 januar 2020 mit hunter deus in
einem sehr interessanten interview
gesessen also ich fand das extrem
spannend weil er auch erklärt hat dass
man diese respiratorischen erkrankungen
gekommen dass man immer versucht sie
zunächst einmal auf zu halten damit es
die
älteren und schwächeren eben später
trifft und damit man das nicht
überlastet aber es gelingt nie dass es
sozusagen so von ihm gesichertes wissen
an tadeusz übergeben worden öffentlich
in einem interview und das hat sich ja
sehr geändert also diese ganze
geschichte hat sich sehr geändert und da
frage ich mich natürlich nach dem
vertrauen das sich in jemanden haben der
uns dann irgendwie eine impfpflicht
geschert und dann kann ich nur sagen
okay dann gucke ich mal zurück zu den
zahlen haben die anderen das gemacht und
ich hoffe ich langweilig ein wenig über
zahlen reden aber auch da müssen wir
natürlich immer gucken gibt es und das
hatten sie gestern im thema mit der lisa
fitz gibt es im nebenwirkungen oder
schwere impfnebenwirkungen die man
betrachten muss und die krankenhausdaten
und ich will da gar nicht die großen
zahlen nennen die ich hier jetzt stehen
habe und ich möchte auch frau fetz da in
keiner form aber ich kann ihnen sagen
dass ich denke dass es richtig nicht
richtig ist jetzt eine impfpflicht
einzuführen bevor man das nicht alles
konkret überprüft hat die daten liegen
vor und meist allein gegen die ihm
schlecht war wie siehst du das ich habe
vor allem ein problem mit unserem recht
habe politikern es ist so eine große
rechthaberei die jetzt stattfindet alle
sehen zahlen alle sehen was gerade
passiert nämlich dass das ursprüngliche
ziel was man mal hatte nicht aufgeht da
ging es ja mal darum man wolle die
ansteckung verhindern dann ging es da um
schwere erkrankungen zu verhindern jetzt
und übernächste über übernächste
erkrankung zu verhindern und damit
keiner mehr schwer krank die wahrheit
ist doch dass diejenigen die die
impfpflicht von anfang an kritisiert
haben zumindest die allgemeine
impfpflicht recht haben und diejenigen
die uns erzählt haben dass das der
richtige weg ist falsch liegen so was
sollte daraus hervorgehen olaf scholz
und die leute um ihn herum sollten
endlich mal aufwachen oder scholz hat
übrigens im rating ein rekordergebnis
nicht eingefahren sondern wurde
abgestuft also das glaube ich um über
fast zweistellig hat den sympathiewerten
verloren und ich glaube das liegt auch
daran dass man einfach stur an einer
politik festhalten will die von der
realität überholt worden ist weil die
politiker sich heutzutage nicht mehr
trauen zu sagen mensch wir haben da
einen fehler gemacht da gibt es neue
erkenntnisse dass erstaunlich ist ja das
aber bei der anderen welle nämlich jetzt
mal christian lindner ist es nämlich der
ja vor der wahl gesagt hat auf gar
keinen fall machen wir das mit der
impfpflicht und da ging es ganz einfach
zu sagen jetzt machen wir ist warum kann
man denn jetzt nicht sagen ja jetzt
sehen wir es wieder so wie vor der wahl
aber jetzt einfach nicht so böse du bist
doch auf einem sehr guten weg du bist
drei mal geimpft es war einmal genießen
also wird sich 0,8 größten hast du schon
ausreichend kraft war wieder ein
bisschen sauer weil ich versuche seit
zwei jahren mich nicht anzustecken und
märkte jetzt ist der falsche weg das ist
bitter also vielleicht hätte ich doch
viel mehr corona partys feiern müssen
ähnliches hat er ist stelle ich mich
nicht bei einer corona partner an gut
das war auf einmal ich habe einiges
hingeflogen war angefangen hat nichts
geholfen ganz schlimm bittere
rückschläge sind vielleicht gibt es bald
immunisierung studies bilder aber es
geht euch doch auch so es wirkt
widersinnig impfpflicht zu fordern auf
der einen seite die menschen die noch
skeptisch sind darum geht es ja bei
gepflegt diejenigen die skeptisch sind
es geht ja nicht nur darum menschen zu
zwingen sich impfen zu lassen dann das
sagen hier gibt es einen brief von
skeptikern oder menschen die wir nicht
erreicht haben aus welchen gründen auch
immer und die wollen wir durch eine
impfpflicht dahin bringen dass sich mehr
menschen hat sich auch impfen dass das
ist ja eigentlich das ziel aber die
dieses ziel höhle ich doch jetzt völlig
aus wenn ich sage wer richtig gut
geimpft bist du nur wenn du dich drei
mal impfen ist drei mal infiziert und
dann auf jahre hinaus heißt ja auch
nicht endgültig geschützt ich kann
ehrlich verschiedener und christian
drosten überhaupt noch zu hört also
dieser podcast den ja alle deutschen am
anfang der korona pandemie gehört haben
also warum
es hat sich doch alles verändert und
überschlagen und bestimmte dinge stimmen
und menschen haben auch angst ich glaube
das ist ein ganz ganz großer punkt viele
menschen haben nach wie vor ganz große
angst und viele menschen halten auch die
omikron variante einfach noch nicht für
sicher und ich glaube die angst der
menschen und die haben in london war ich
da wurde ich gefragt warum eigentlich
auch in der gesellschaft in den medien
so viel panik geschürt wurde in england
hätte man mehr verschiedene standpunkte
von anfang an gehabt und ich glaube das
wird ganz lange dauern vor allem die
panik aus der gesellschaft zu kriegen
gab es dass er interessante was wir
gesehen haben in dieser corona pandemie
ist die unterschiedlichen mentalitäten
mit denen unterschiedliche länder daran
gegangen sind dass man ja das absolut
faszinierend ich war beim g 7 gipfel im
juni letzten jahres in cornwall und da
musste bot an oder ja denn für alle die
es noch nicht wussten ja ein teil 1 teil
englands und er musste berichten sind
gerade den eigentlich angesetzten
frieden day wieder einsammeln und weil
die zahlen etwas nach oben ging und das
wo der lockt obwohl also noch ein
bisschen verlängert das führt aber nicht
dazu dass man jetzt die papst
geschlossen hat also man
selbstverständlich hat mal weiter
draußen gesessen und die briten dann wie
gesagt ja gut aber das müssen wir jetzt
länger machen aber wir stellen uns
deshalb unser lebensstil nicht um die
dänen haben es ähnlich wir haben wir
haben alles gemacht was man von ihnen
verlangt hat sie haben sich auch nicht
impfen lassen aber jetzt trotz hoher
instanzen machen sie wieder auf die
deutschen sind da immer sehr stark regel
fixiert und komme klar ich immer wieder
mit ganz viel abstand hat vielleicht
auch geholfen kurzfristig aber bei dem
thema impfpflicht finde ich dann muss
bitte die regierung wenn sie ernsthaft
dafür votiert ich bin gegen eine
impfpflicht bin sehr fürs impfen chart
nix aber da muss die regierung bitte
schön sagen was ist eigentlich der
effekt dieses impfen also haben wir das
auch mal die begründung grundlage an
also der expertenrat ist ja so zur seite
der ethikrat ist ja sozusagen das
expertengremium für die bundesregierung
wenn sie sich mit einer impfpflicht
beschäftigen da muss es ja eine sehr
hohe begründung last geben damit man das
überhaupt zwangsweise oder pflicht artig
mit bußgeldern oder so was wir vor uns
sehen dass man das begründen kann und
der einzige oder das gremium ist der
ethikrat und wenn man sich das anguckt
dann ist das ja anders als bei masern
amazon war das ja früher auch schon so
dass es da eine impfpflicht gegeben hat
die man gründet hat aber mit dem
fremdschutz und dass diese ad-hoc
stellungnahme des ethikrates habe ich
mir genau durchgelesen und ich habe
festgestellt die einzige begründung
warum eine impfpflicht zurzeit ist und
vielleicht weil das jetzt noch nicht so
bekannt aber die einzige begründung ist
die überlastung des gesundheitssystems
zu verändern und da kommen wir gleich
noch zu aber da habe ich jetzt
eigentlich ganz warten bei der
allgemeinen kriegsheim uns hier sehr
meiner meinung am tisch zu sein weil wie
siehst du die berufsbezogenen pflicht
mehr wähler ja wie gesagt im pflicht
macht für mich sinn und eine
berufsbezogene impfpflicht ebenso wie
bisher weil weil man davon ausgehen
musste dass diejenigen die zu tun haben
mit besonders ungeschützt menschen
besonders kranken und dergleichen hier
einen besonderen schutz gewährleisten
müssen auch in der frage in der tatsache
geschuldet dass sie geimpft sind also
wenn ich als pfleger jemanden behandelt
der vielleicht herzkrank ist der
aufgrund von schwächen sich nicht impfen
lassen können dann muss ich als
krankenhaus und auch als fürsorge aus
fürsorgepflicht davon ausgehen müssen
dass derjenige eben
nicht ansteckend ist wir wissen nun auch
als geimpfter kann ich ansteckend sein
ich kann mich infizieren ich kann
ansteckend sein und nach der lehre jetzt
von der osten soll ich drei mal geimpft
und reimer infiziert sein damit ich eben
möglichst gut geschützt und vielleicht
auch das müssen die zahlen belegen aber
am wenigsten anrufer wenn ich als
geimpfter es trotzdem weiter tragen kann
dann kann ich das als pfleger doch genau
an diese schutzengel weitergeben größte
und dann frage ich mich was die was die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht dann
bringen soll also ich selbst schütze
mich nicht ich schütze aber links auch
den pflegen zu pflegenden patienten
nicht gut ich habe einen milderen
verlauf das ist sicherlich sehr schön
aber aber dass schutz argument also die
menschen die andere pflegen sollen sich
impfen lassen wenn sie es dann trotz der
impfung weitergeben und möglicherweise
jemand mit vorerkrankungen dann stirbt
dann habe ich das ziel gar nicht
erreicht ich möchte einfach von der
politik die mir eine maßnahme auferlegt
wissen was ist das ziel damit ich die
politik hinterher daran messen kann ob
das ziel erreicht wird ob es das
der ob die maßnahme zwingend war ob sie
angemessen war und ob sie zu dem ziel
geführt hat wenn dass die politik gar
nicht definieren kann dann kann ich
nicht irgendeine pflicht einfach
ausgeben und so lange wir probieren das
x mal sehen ob es geklappt aber müssen
wir auch nicht